Nhìn mồn và ngạc, xây dừng chứ bà một số tình lũ để mỗi năm sân hợi.
Thành đến bố tư gia đình, thế hoang lình nghĩa là khi chúng ta xây dừng gòn, tại chính thức bà.
Mồn một số tình, mà số tình ló ngạc, mỗi năm, chúng ta vọng tích tục liền lần tư dừng như là lưới kìm.
Bối số tình này, mỗi năm chúng ta chỉ còn rất xa hỏng bố hình chăm, trên hỏng lại dùng bố hình chăm này lũ chỉ trả phòng vô.
Vì phí trọng đẹp của chúng ta đẹp.
Ló là khán những hình ở dựa này chính và tại sao lại có số bố hình chăm.
Bởi vì bước lại số trung bình, trên thị trường dừng thầy, theo các cân lần lời trung bình mà ở cái mức an còn,
là sẽ hòa quan tàn hỏng tầy mấy tất cả mừng chăm thôi.
Thì chăm ló, phí lạm thái trung bình ở Việt Nam là khoảng 3 cái bố hình chăm này.
Và trường là cái chăm đẹp có, mấy bố hình chăm lần lời trung hợp.
Vì vậy, như bố hình phà là thái xây dừng thì các thàn một số tình lấu,
là mỗi năm, sinh là, cái trung thả lúc phà múng như chăm lắm lần rồi, là tựa này chính.
Nhưng mà, là tầy mga cái cắt nợ là thịt, lắm phải lời hầy chăm mắc phải bảo nắm.
Với cái mức trịt với lãm một bố chăm lần lần lần lần lần lần trịt chăm lần thái.
Thì sợ tầy mấy cố mà, lãm một bố nè tựa này chính của anh là sẽ hoàn tàn,
để số bán nó tìm.